[Music]
and
pop it like that
hi i'm olivia boisson i'm a quarter
valley member with the new york city
ballet
every dancer is trying to make their
point you a part of them so they want to
mold it to their foot as much as
possible so there's a lot involved to
make that happen
it's really important because we have
them on from 10 am to 11 pm so you want
to make sure that there's nothing
bothering you so you fix them and fix
them until they're right if i'm
performing and rehearsing a lot it could
be up to three pairs a day they aren't
very strong
when you're working with them all day so
they typically do die pretty fast
regular ballet flats are just very soft
they're usually canvas or leather you
can't go up on point with them pointers
are normally a bit harder so that you
can get up on your toes
and
men
typically wear the ballet flats and
women normally wear them to warm up but
not always point shoes are around eighty
to ninety dollars a pair at least that's
how much they were when i was growing up
but the company
gives all the point shoes for free so we
we have as many as we need
[Music]
every dancer sews their point shoes
differently all to support your ankle
and in different ways i put mine
a little bit
further forward probably like an inch
away from this seam
i'm just going to smush the box the
boxes where your toes go and it's
typically pretty
tough and pretty hard when you get a new
shoe and so you want it to be a little
bit more malleable so that you can
move your toes inside the box so i'm
going to swish them
i need to be able to move that part so
i'm going to stick my heel in the middle
and
pop it like that so that now i can
bend this part of the shoe this is
called the shank kind of like your arch
support but you want it to bend so that
you can point your foot
[Music]
so
[Music]
so now
they bend in here and they've been here
so it's a little bit easier for me to
get my foot in there now i'm gonna um
bang them because um they're still
pretty loud
and when you're dancing it's very
distracting
i usually
will put a little second skin they're
like little gel squares
so i usually put them at the tips of my
big toes because that is where most of
the pressure is when i'm on point and
then i tape them so that they stay on
and then
i'm gonna
put
the elastic here and then i'm gonna put
my paper towels on
[Music]
i just want to get a good
um
bend in my shoe which is why i'm like
pushing them out like this
[Music]
i feel pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so now the bottom of the shoe
is all um
not as smooth so it's harder to like
slip
so this is rosin you can like smash it
and it becomes powder
and you kind of
just
wipe your foot like the edges that are
slippery and it's a lot less
slippery sometimes the very
tip here will get very soft so then i
will use this hot glue
to harden it back up again that way you
don't have to like sew a whole new shoe
you can sort of make this last a little
bit longer some dancers will put it on
the outside sometimes they do that too
give it a little bit more support
at the top so that it's not so soft when
you get up so the new pair you it just
really keeps you all the way up with a
dead pair it'd get really soft in here
everything would just be much more soft
so it's harder to dance hours and hours
when the shoe isn't keeping you up you
have to do a lot more work
you